>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[Music]
>> HELENA ZINKHAM: The
Library of Congress is home
to the Rosa Parks Collection,
on loan from the Howard G.
Buffett Foundation for 10 years.
Mr. Buffett decided to purchase
this special material in 2014,
when he learned that it was
languishing in an auction warehouse.
He wanted to bring these rare
items back into public view
and ensure their preservation.
Rosa Parks was a seminal figure
of the Civil Rights Movement.
Her collection reveals how deeply
she believed in a moral imperative
to oppose discrimination and
the denial of individual rights.
That belief most famously
resulted in her decision
to challenge the bus segregation
laws in Montgomery, Alabama in 1955.
But, her autobiographical
writings in this collection,
they reveal numerous
times in her life
when that conviction
motivated her to act.
The collection documents many
aspects of her private life as well
as her public work on behalf of
civil rights for African Americans.
While the 7,500 manuscript documents
and the 2,500 photographs span
140 years, the content focuses
on the decades of the
1950s through the 1990s.
This includes Mrs. Parks' own
writings, letters from presidents,
her Congressional Gold Medal, her
Presidential Medal of Freedom,
and wonderful hand-drawn
cards of appreciation
from scores of school children.
What follows now, are
highlights from the collection
and a look behind the scenes at how
our team of experts in cataloging,
preservation, digitization,
exhibition, and teacher training,
how they are all making this legacy
of Rosa Parks available
to the world.
We are deeply honored to have
been selected as the steward
of the Rosa Parks Collection.
>> HOWARD BUFFETT: I think
it's so important for us
to remember the iconic
figures that changed our lives
and that gave us what we have
and preserved what we have.
And so, an African-American woman in
the 1950s to do what Rosa Parks did,
showed how much difference
one person can make.
It's important for our
children to see that
and to really embrace
it and understand it.
Without getting this collection
out of the boxes and out
of the warehouse and in front of
people, that wasn't going to happen.
And so, I thought we should, make
sure that this was in a place
where millions of people can see it
and benefit from it and, obviously,
the Library of Congress, there's
no place better than this facility
and this team to do that.
>> MARICIA BATTLE: We have a
very large collection that deals
with civil rights and so it was
sort of a fulfillment of a dream
to have the person who
they considered the mother
of the Civil Rights Movement,
come into the collections.
>> ADRIENNE CANNON: The Rosa Parks
Collection will illuminate other
facets of her life, her family
life, her Christian faith
and spirituality, her activism
post Montgomery bus boycott,
and it will also shed additional
light on some of the details
of the Montgomery bus boycott.
>> MARICIA BATTLE: Most
people have the perception
that Rosa Parks was
the lady who wore pink,
the lady who always had a beautiful
purse, a beautiful hat on her head,
and she was this quiet voice
that sort of spoke to you.
But, I think one of the things
they'll realize after looking at
and viewing this collection,
is that she was a lion
underneath all of that.
She had a way of softly drawing
you in and then sort of hitting you
with the facts just
square between the eyes.
And I think they'll be surprised.
>> MEG MCALEER: Every
collection tells a story,
well actually many stories.
And the first thing I do when I
approach a collection is to try
to discover what those stories are.
And I do this by assessing
the scope of a collection
and the relationship
between the parts.
The collection came to us
stored in these cartons.
And in the cartons, papers were
grouped together in large envelopes.
I've completed my initial
survey and I came
up with broad categories
to arrange the papers.
For instance, I have a category
of family correspondence.
This is the largest cache of letters
actually written by Rosa Parks
in the collection and
they're very revealing.
One that moves me in
particular is a letter she wrote
to someone she addresses
as, Dear friend.
I don't know who the person is.
It's written on Montgomery
Fair stationary.
She was employed at Montgomery Fair
at the time she refused to give
up her seat on the bus
on December 1, 1955.
In this letter, she tries to set
what happened to her on December 1st
in a broader context
of the Jim Crow South.
She explains that segregation
is complete
and a solid pattern-
it is the way we live.
And then she goes on to describe
the experiences of people on buses,
having to go to segregated public
schools, churches, public libraries.
And then also what it was like
to work at Montgomery Fair
where she could not use the
restrooms used by white employees
or the employee lounges and
she was not allowed to sit
at the counter and have her lunch.
But, at the end of the letter,
she closes with something
that indicates the
gravity of the situation,
that goes beyond the indignities of
the daily slaps of discrimination.
She ends the letter by asking
if this person had heard
about the lynch murder of Emmett
Till, the 14 year old teenager
from Chicago who was visiting family
in Mississippi in August, 1955,
when he allegedly flirted
with a married white woman.
And for this, he was
brutally murdered.
She later tells Till's
mother that at that moment
when she was deciding whether to get
up from her seat on that bus or not,
she thought about her son,
she thought about Emmett Till.
>> ANITA PEEK: On the day that
she was arrested, she was sitting
where she was supposed to
sit in the colored section.
But, at that time, they used to
move the sign if they chose to.
And the back of the bus was already
crowded so she didn't have to get
up if there was no more seats
further back in the bus.
And when the bus driver asked
for the four people to stand,
none of them stood originally.
But after he threatened jail,
the other three got up,
but she kept sitting.
>> ADRIENNE CANNON:
Rosa Parks' arrest
for refusing a bus driver's
order to surrender her seat
to a white passenger, happened
on December the 1st, 1955.
There was no media present.
There were no reporters
or photographers
to take photographs of the incident.
The photograph that
is known worldwide
that shows Rosa Parks
sitting on the bus
with a white man sitting behind
her, was taken a year later
on December 21st, 1956, the
first day that the buses
in Montgomery, Alabama
were integrated.
A month after the Montgomery
bus boycott began,
Rosa Parks lost her 25 dollar a
week job as an assistant tailor
at the Montgomery Fair
department store
when it closed its tailor shop.
Her husband, Raymond was
forced to resign his job
at a private barber's concession
in Maxwell Field Air Force Base.
In 1957, Rosa, Raymond, and her
mother, Leona, moved to Detroit
to join her brother, Sylvester.
She worked for 8 years
as a seamstress before
becoming an office receptionist
and administrative assistant
for newly-elected Congressman,
John Conyers in 1965.
And she served as his liaison with
the black community in Detroit.
She kept abreast of all community
activities, attended rallies,
and she particularly dealt with his
constituents' needs with concerns
about welfare benefits, social
security, and job discrimination.
>> MARICIA BATTLE: The
relationship that Mrs. Parks had
with John Conyers was a very close
and kind one, as you can tell
from this photo that
Conyers dedicated to her.
And it's signed, "to the mother of
the Civil Rights Movement, with love
and thanks, John Conyers,
July 22, 1985."
One of the other pieces that we find
is this image of both Rosa Parks
and Conyers protesting in front
of the General Motors
warehouse or factory.
Protesting the closing, because so
many African Americans worked there,
they thought this was unfair for
this particular plant to close.
>> JOHN CONYERS: One day she came
to me and said, "Congressman,
I'd like to ask for
a pay reduction."
I said, "I beg your pardon?"
Nobody's ever asked for that before.
Nobody's ever asked for
it since [laughter].
And she said, "Well, you know,
you let me go so many places here
in the country and even overseas."
And I said, "Mrs. Parks, you
honor me by coming to my office
and having worked with
me for so long."
And it was no secret that more
people came to see Rosa Parks
in my office than came to see me!
[Music]
>> MARY MUNDY: Preparing
collections for scholars
to use involves a lot
of different activities.
One of the first things I
do is survey the materials,
get familiar with the
subject content
and formats represented
in the collection.
Then the next thing I
do is always look to see
if the collection is organized.
If there's a logical organization,
I want to keep that organization.
If the collection lacks
any organization I'll need
to impose an order that's
conducive to research.
Next, formats with special
storage requirements are separated
from the rest of the material.
For instance, photographic
negatives need to be stored
at cold temperatures for
preservation purposes.
Large objects and fragile
items need to be stored flat
in special boxes fit to their size.
Additional work involves
placing items
in containers, folders and sleeves.
And every object has to be numbered
with the collection
storage information
so they can be easily
identified on the shelf.
And items pulled can
be refiled after use.
The final step involves describing
the collection in the form
of a catalog record with
subject headings and lots
of other access points so
scholars can find the material
in our online catalog.
All of these pictures really
reflect her lifelong commitment
to civil rights, her work with
youth and her dedication to family.
This is a very early photograph
of her husband Raymond
Parks and his sister.
This is unique in the sense that
it's mounted on a metal frame
that is decorated with
a landscape scene.
Rosa Parks had a lifelong interest
in helping youth and educating them
about African American history.
She started working with youth
actually in the late '40s
with the NAACP youth council.
This piece represents the impact
that Rosa Parks had on children.
And it's a greeting card actually
from a group of school children
that was sent to her in 1998 and one
of the largest greeting
cards we have
in the collection from
school children.
>> ADRIENNE CANNON: In 1987 she
co-founded with Elaine Steele,
the Rosa and Raymond Parks Institute
for Self Development as a tribute
to her late husband, Raymond
who passed away in 1977.
The purpose of the
institute was to motivate
and direct the average youth
not targeted by other programs,
towards achieving their
highest potential.
>> MARICIA BATTLE: So, her
legacy is to instill in children,
no matter how small your beginning,
there's no end to what
you can achieve.
So, here are photos of Rosa Parks
at the John Freeman Walls
historic site in Canada.
She's surrounded by children.
One of the things that she
did with the institute,
is they have a Pathways to
Freedom, where they take children
onto different sites of
the Underground Railroad,
and the Walls site is thought
to be one of the last sites
on that Underground Railroad.
Here we have, in Detroit, in
the 90's, a camp, a day camp,
again, surrounded by children.
She and Raymond did
not have any children,
but her brother, Sylvester, had 13.
>> ELAINE STEELE: When
children came into her midst,
there was a wonderful smile
that came on her face.
Didn't matter how young they were,
you know, up into their teen years.
And if they were interested
in learning,
she was just endeared to them more.
[Music]
>> ANDREW ROBB: In the conservation
division, we treat a wide variety
of special collection items.
So, that might mean
mending tears or for books,
taking the binding
apart and rebinding it.
For photographs, it could be
removing tape or consolidating edges
where there's small parts of the
photograph that have flaked off.
So, what we're really
trying to focus
on with treatment is stabilizing
things so that future generations
of the public and readers
can use them.
So, the Rosa Parks collection
requires some amount of treatment.
These are mainly mid-century to late
century twentieth century materials.
So we have photographs,
manuscript materials,
books, scrapbooks and albums.
And we think that Rosa
Parks or someone
in her family made this album.
While we could just focus just on
the photographs, we work together
with our curators and our book
conservators to think carefully
about the object itself
and what we need to do
to preserve the whole thing.
A term we like to use is
the integrity of the object.
The album is an album
and we want to retain
that format as much as possible.
>> MARICIA BATTLE: One of the
things that impressed me is the fact
that she had managed to hold on
to all of the family photographs
and kept them in really
good condition.
Here, for instance, is a
great image of her father.
And an early and later photograph
of her mother Leona, with a cousin,
and Leona is the one
seated in the chair.
Another interesting fact
about the visual materials is
that we do finally
get to see the photos
of her husband, Raymond Parks.
And what's interesting about that is
because Rosa Parks was
basically the major person
that everyone concentrated on,
so Mr. Parks was always
in the background.
So, to know that she carried
a photo in her wallet of him,
and that he was always by her
side, just tells you the role
that he played for her, basically.
>> ADRIENNE CANNON: Rosa McCauley
met Raymond Parks in 1931.
She was particularly impressed
with the fact that he was engaged
in what she called
the racial situation.
And she remarked that he was the
first person outside of her family
who she discussed racial
politics with and engaged Rosa
in the national campaign to
defend the Scottsboro Boys.
They married in 1932.
Raymond always wore a suit, and so
he is the man here in the dark suit.
And he's surrounded by
his friends and customers.
Another item in the collection
that we have is a family bible
that records the records of several
generations of Rosa Parks' family,
the Edwards', the Percival's,
the McCauley's, the Nobel's.
>> ALAN HALEY: The bible
came to us in pieces.
It showed evidence of
handling and tears.
So we had to use Asian papers
to fill in those losses
and they're quite extensive.
We use Asian papers because they're
chemically stable, they're strong,
and yet they're very flexible.
So, it will integrate with
the original materials
to make it very functional.
The sewing was, for
the most part, gone.
So, we need to give it a new sewing
structure which will allow the Bible
to be flexible enough to open safely
for researchers in the future.
The spine was missing, so
we will need to dye clothe
in a sympathetic color to the
covers, which we still have,
to put a new spine on the book.
And much of it seemed
to be out of order.
We know, of course, that the
core of the bible is from Genesis
to Revelation- that
part is easy to collate.
But, there are many, many
pages probably over 150 leaves
of supplemental materials,
not paginated.
And we don't know how to put
this back together again.
I'm also working with bible scholars
at the American Bible Society.
So we're trying to find out
which year it was published
and that will give us a solid
record of the order of the materials
that are included within.
I think the part that
would be of most interest
to scholars would be the registry
in the middle where the births
and deaths of the Parks
family are recorded.
It does go back to
the 1880's-1870's.
[Music]
>> PHIL MICHEL: Because
the collections we have
to scan are many sizes and varieties
and types- some is photography,
some manuscripts, some books,
we have digitization equipment
that can handle a wide
variety of materials.
Some of them are flatbed type
scanners or digital cameras
on copy stands and the like.
Digitization is very
important for collections
because it really gives
us the opportunity
to share these collections
with the world.
Anybody who has access to a computer
can now see and view these items
without having to come
to Washington, DC.
It gives us a chance to provide
an image surrogate without having
to repeatedly handle the
collections over and over again.
So, they can be stored
in a proper environment
and hopefully they'll last
a very long time this way.
The scanning produces images of
such high quality that researchers,
they really can zoom in and see
all of the details of the original.
Well, sometimes even more details
than what you could really see
viewing the image right onsite.
So we're really happy that
people can get into that depth
of research using these
high resolution images.
It's really gratifying
to work with a collection
like the Rosa Parks collection
because there's so much interest
in it and so much demand.
And for a lot of people who
aren't aware of the Library
and the services we provide and
the richness of our collections,
it's a great opportunity to
show and share with the world,
help everyone be able
to access and see them,
and appreciate them
for what they are.
[Music]
>> JEFF FLANNERY: Anyone
over the age
of 16 can use the library's
collections as long
as they get a valid
reader registration card.
However, some of the
reading rooms, for instance,
the Manuscript reading room,
require special conditions for use.
Most of the users in
our reading room are
from the academic community.
However, we've had a
children's author come
in and is using the papers.
We've had congressional staff
come in and use the collections.
We have a wide variety of research
use using the Parks papers.
Her papers are here in the reading
room complimenting many other
collections that we have that
relate to the Civil Rights Movement
in the twentieth century
in the United States.
So, she sits next to the records of
the NAACP, the largest collection
that we have, the records of
the National Urban League,
the papers of Frederick
Douglas, and A. Philip Randolph,
and James Foreman and other leaders
in the Civil Rights Movement.
So, her papers compliment
the collections
and they will gain insight into
the struggles during the twentieth
century for the Civil
Rights Movement.
[Music]
>> ADRIENNE CANNON: Because
of the breadth and richness
of our civil rights resources,
we were able to easily incorporate
items from the Rosa Parks papers
in our recent exhibit
commemorating the 50th anniversary
of the Civil Rights Act of 1964,
a Long Struggle for Freedom.
We looked specifically at items in
the Rosa Parks papers that related
to the Montgomery bus boycott.
>> CARROLL JOHNSON-WELSH: Rosa
Parks was a dispatcher at the time
in the Montgomery Improvement
Association.
Here, she gives instructions to
carpoolers and drivers participating
in the Montgomery bus boycott,
asking them to "do not call
for transportation if you are
in reasonable walking
distance to your job."
She also asked them to remember
"how long some of us had to wait
when the buses passed
us without stopping
in the morning and evening."
The second item is a
Hallmark calendar issued
by Montgomery Fair Department store
where Rosa Parks was a seamstress.
On this particular page, it has
listed the drivers of the boycott.
And at the top, we have the
name, King listed along with some
of the other leaders in
the first group of drivers.
The last name is Nixon, who was
her mentor during the NAACP period
of her life.
And then the 3rd item we have is
a flyer announcing her speaking
engagement at Sharp Street
Methodist Church in Baltimore, MD.
She was requested by many throughout
the United States to come and speak
on the behalf of the
NAACP, and so this is one
of her first speaking engagements.
The goal of the Interpretive
Programs Office is
to bring the Library's collections
to the public, nationally
and internationally through
our physical exhibitions,
our online exhibitions,
our traveling exhibitions,
our cultural partnerships, and
through our public programs.
I've personally have talked
to thousands of visitors
that have come through
the exhibition.
I've talked to people from Europe.
I've talked to people from
within the United States,
South America, and Canada.
They are finding out new information
about Rosa Parks beyond
her stance on the bus.
>> PAUL BEVERLY: I always get chills
when I see the original materials.
There's just something
very authentic
about seeing an actual letter or
the actual flag that the NAACP flew
or the actual piece of music
that Charles Mingus
wrote, in his own hand.
Just seeing that just a few
inches in front of you and knowing
that a real person
was connected to that.
So, it's a wonderful exhibit.
[Music]
>> LEE ANN POTTER: Educational
Outreach at the Library
of Congress is the unit that is
dedicated to serving teachers.
We develop professional development
opportunities from workshops
to Summer Institutes to
sessions at conferences.
We also develop resources
that we make available
through the Library's website.
We write articles for
professional journals.
And in all of these
instances, what we are trying
to do is get primary source
documents- photographs, letters,
journal entries, drawings,
newspaper articles,
into the hands of classroom
teachers.
One of our Summer teacher
institutes focused specifically
on the Civil Rights movement and we
were able to include a wide variety
of materials from the
Rosa Parks collection
and we also hosted a very
special panel where individuals
who had known Rosa Parks, described
to our teachers their experiences
in the civil rights movement.
>> KAREN SHER: My students
are sort of numb
to the notion of the struggle.
And I always talk about Mamie Till,
and I always talk about Rosa Parks,
and I always talk about Martin
Luther King and Malcolm X,
like they were so far
away, even from me.
And this week has really taught
me that it's not that far away.
That you know, Rosa Parks' best
friends are here talking to us
about what it was like to be
in those moments with her.
And not because of fanfare or
celebrity, but because of love.
And it's something I try really
hard to instill in my students.
>> LILA CABBIL: Her courage
and her strength had everything
to do with her spirituality.
So, her staying in her
seat was her own decision
and she knew who had her back.
>> JOE MADISON: She was a
different kind of militant.
You'd never see her raise her fists.
It wasn't the black
panther type of militant.
It was a real militancy
that in essence says,
"I'm gonna stand my ground."
>> ROBERTA MCLEOD: She always
encouraged young people,
"do your best.
No matter what someone else
is doing, do your best."
And she believed as educators,
we had a responsibility
to encourage our young
people to do their best.
>> GEOFFREY MILLS: I think what
I'm getting from this week together
with the others, is that we should
allow students an opportunity
to explore what they're
seeing in a document.
Give them opportunity to
bring their own experiences,
their own lived experiences,
interpretations, to
what they're seeing.
And through collaboration,
come to some type
of understanding of
what it all means.
>> KATIE FEENEY: Well, I learned
about like how she really like stood
up for herself and even
like how they all had
to go to the back of the bus.
And it just like really makes
me like appreciate what she did.
And I just think that like what
they had to do was completely unfair
and that it really makes
me like appreciate.
>> MACKENZIE LEE: I learned
that she got a lot of awards
for her bravery on
that bus that day.
And that made me feel really,
really lucky that I'm
born in this time period.
That we're all the same and equal.
That's what I learned.
>> DILLON STONE: I think
Rosa Parks had a huge impact
on our community today.
And that without her, people would
still be discriminated based off
of their race.
[Music]
>> JOHN CONYERS: By refusing to
give up her seat and standing
for equal rights, Rosa
Parks inspired a nation
and became a legendary
example of the value
of a single courageous act.
At a time when our nation
faces challenges, both domestic
and global, I believe
that the example
of Rosa Parks remains
relevant to every citizen.
>> ANITA PEEK: She believed that all
human beings should have the right
to be educated, should
have the right to be free
and should have the right
to be treated justly.
She believed in justice.
>> ELAINE STEELE: That's
what she wanted in life.
You know, that people
understand one another
and have that human kindness.
And, as you learn more about
others, then it indeed inspires you.
>> ADRIENNE CANNON: We
were fortunate to receive
in the collection, both Rosa Parks'
Presidential Medal of Freedom
and the Congressional Gold Medal.
In 1996, President Bill Clinton
awarded Rosa Parks the Presidential
Medal of Freedom in recognition
of the role that she played
in sparking the Montgomery
bus boycott,
and the role the bus boycott, in
turn, played in evoking a new phase
of the modern Civil Rights Movement.
The Presidential Medal of
Freedom is the highest honor
in the nation awarded to a civilian.
In 1999, Congress awarded Rosa
Parks the Congressional Gold Medal,
the highest honor that
Congress bestows on a civilian.
>> ANITA PEEK: Congresswoman
Julia Carson who's deceased now,
she was very surprised that
Mrs. Parks had not received the
Congressional Gold Medal prior
to her entering Congress.
And she worked very
hard with many others
to make sure that it happened.
>> ELLA MCCALL HAYGAN: Congresswomen
Carson, she was a dynamite person
and she would say, "Ms.
Parks you needed to have
that medal a long time ago!"
And she would just laugh at her,
she thought she was really funny.
Every time I look at
the medal and think
about the medal, I
think about that day.
>> ANITA PEEK: She always seemed
to be surprised that people thought
that what she did was so important.
She felt that she made
a decision that day
that no matter whether she lived
or died, that it was important
to stop giving in when you
were doing the right thing.
She really believed
in right and wrong.
>> HOWARD BUFFETT: Rosa
Parks was all about freedom
and you're sitting here in
Washington, DC and this is
where our freedom is preserved.
And so I think that to have
this collection sitting here
in our capital is exactly
where it should be.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.